si è affacciato comunque a mare stiamo
pensando che potresti farmi una bella
svolta in questo angolino tipici tramite
un molare sicura chiesto storia
[Musica]
bellissima spetta bella da vedere sto
giro non ti puoi lamentare chiamo amore
ma c'è sono alta un metro ogni volta
sono alta un metro mi fai le foto da
tante sono ancora più schiacciante una
cosa fate le fare da un fotografo ciao
ma c'è un assegno finanza dovresti
tenerci alle mie foto ma punta
se vuoi dirmi qualcosa però cioè ogni
volta 6 zitto e qui ti lamenti che
parliamo due ore di mille cose come mi
devo mettere sto venendo bene cioè non
lo so e non parlava
amore sei top6 devastante aspetta guardi
la guardia
bellissima
amare come stanno venendo band
vediamo
ma va bene si è impegnato molto e vedo
no grazie
tonia amore sei pronta per lo shooting
della vita dai dai
ok ok ok allora stammi a sentire vuoi
continuare ad avere il profilo come
quelle che ritiene delle tue amiche che
si fanno i salti con la bocca papera
cosa vuoi fare
dimmelo perché se non vado via ok dammi
di più va bene dammi di più
ok guarda gli altri guarda in alto
proprio come se fossi baciato dalla
lucidità
più di più
scusate scusate devo dire una cosa
seguimi
ora chi è così facendo amore una cosa
così non ricapiterà mai più è un
fotografo di vogue quindi symbol e mani
io mi lascio vado a prendere un caffè
ci vediamo dopo mi raccomando ragazzi
grazie
se si guarda bene
vorrei sono tutte sfocate a tutte non ce
n'è una sana oppure è arte tumblr questo
tablet ma lo vedo il concetto guarda
troppo svuotate girati
non malaccio
che esposto di ancora
amore cosa nota che stanno venendo
l'amore non fate 182 questo guardando
secondo me qualcuno che ti piace c'è
fine a vedere nel caso delle faccio
altro
vediamo
allora queste sovraesposta mi sembra che
sia da copione
quanti brufoli cioè non c'è non c'è da
dove mi ha fatto uscire bene non c'è
amore anche scaricato 3.000 per
modificare le foto dava gli metti due
filtri astenuti come cambia il genere
mai allora io te lo dico ti faccio due
foto non ho intenzione di perdere tutto
il pomeriggio qua ok sta bene a mare
stai tranquillo
di giorno sono volta non so quale
scegliere
questa
[Musica]
spesso